[Música]
o psol sejam bem vindos a mais um vídeo
e hoje vou ensinar como fazer com uma
serra elétrica
a minha ideia inicialmente era mostrar
como é que isto funciona no final do
paraíba e isso não é assim tão má idéia
se isso for incluído um pouco mais seria
um produto bastante interessante
imaginem vocês vão e comprou uma
furadeira mas porque precisam também de
uma serra elétrica e que vocês não
querem gastar muito na serra elétrica
seria engraçado vocês poderem comprar um
suporte em que você encaixar uma
furadeira e aí que já tenha uma serra
elétrica é muito barata
[Música]
mas só encontrei aqui alguns problemas
que vocês podem evitar fazê los lá em
casa que são os seguintes
é muito importante que a lâmina fique
bem apertada entre os parafusos quando o
deputado é o suficiente pela se mexer
mas não podem andar a apanhar muito em
outra coisa vocês podem usar outro tipo
de exame não seja mais resistente
aquelas mesmo que cortar madeira porque
esta aqui é para cortar metal e é muito
fraquinha e dobra fácil domingo
é isso chegamos ao fim só espero que
vocês tenham gostado se tiver alguma
sugestão de algum projeto é só deixar
nos comentários
eis o projeto total